[Applause]
he may be the underdog but for team
rishi this isn't over yet
[Applause]
it would take a huge upset for the
former chancellor to become the next
prime minister as this long and winding
race draws to a close
there is still a firm favourite
you'll be aware in france they've talked
about the possibility of energy
rationing
can you rule that out liz trust
i do rule that out
okay
but as rishi sunak's allies rally one
last time a final plea to the party
faithful he is a leader all of us can
trust
i'm ready for rishi i hope you are too
from the former chancellor there was
praise for his rival and thanks for his
family acceptance perhaps that this is
nearly over 18 years ago
you chose
to give up your high heels and take a
chance on the short kid with a backpack
i will lead a government
that is conducted competently
that is conducted seriously
and with decency and integrity at the
heart of everything that we do
and for the first time since this
contest began rishi sunak and liz trust
on stage together a final show of unity
after a bruising contest the tone
tonight felt much more friendly but this
is a race that is ending just as it
started with very different visions for
the economy but outside this hall the
cost of living crisis has been laid bare
and that will be the real challenge
whoever becomes prime minister
[Music]
and as the race draws to a close the man
who's still prime minister bidding his
farewell on a last dash around the
country today boris johnson's legacy
will loom over the next government
whoever the top team may be do you think
this race has gone on too long
it's right that we test the candidates
this is a really serious job at probably
the most difficult time it's right we
test them but i know
everyone will be glad it's over very
soon and we can move on in less than a
week the country will be moving on with
a new prime minister
how are you feeling about a potential
liz trust premiership this time next
week
absolutely confident
only then will they begin the much
bigger task of governing annie sku sky
news